[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
one
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
one
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one
[Music]
so
[Music]
one
[Music]
[Music]
one
[Music]
hey ladies and gentlemen it's tuesday
today
yeah here we are talking about another
movie everybody's here
[ __ ] mango's in here sophie's in
there
yeah everybody i really like i really
like the little uh halloween emoji there
although tom says it looks different on
my on my laptop as
it looks on his but like i said the
emojis look different on
macs and pcs and across different
platforms and stuff i just showed uh
i showed sophie uh morrissey she
actually loves morrissey morrissey and
i can smith well i think the smiths like
got us all through our
yeah through our awkward issues
[Laughter]
yeah sophie's [ __ ] uh sophie's
[ __ ] um
morrissey name her gender-bending
morrissey name would be benji
i'm just gonna start calling her benji
so all right fair enough so if you were
in the army you actually just been
called benji
yeah because they call you by your last
name well yeah and if it's a girl that
kind of feminized the last name see she
would just be called benji
yeah yeah that's kind of cool that's
kind of cool
yeah i so i would have just been called
ash or
ash you'd have been called ash or mitch
which is my maiden name they would have
called you ashford and then it would
have broken been broken down to ash
it's funny because there's actually a
girl i think um there's like a the
horror girl on the
what culture youtube show she always
talks about hormones and her name is ash
i don't know if that's her real name
or she just named herself after bruce
campbell and evil dead but you know
that was short for ashley actually but
uh yeah so we're here talking about
another movie
this one i dug this one a lot
i did not think that you would like this
one when i first saw the trailer
but you ended up really liking this one
too right yeah um
the deal with this movie is that um it's
kind of an example of
how much you can do with very little
money
this didn't cost very much to make
eleven thousand dollars that's it
yep damn i looked it up when i the
acting is good the
the script is good the edits good it's
got a good
soundtrack if you want to call it that
it's more like a um
it's a soundtrack in the way that the
soundtrack
for um hills have eyes as it sounds like
a soundscape more like a soundscape
and it's very kind of industrial
sounding in a way
kind of like in the same way uh kind of
like from the thing
you know john carpenter's the thing
where it's mostly just like ambient
sounds
yeah which worked real well uh
cast is cool it's a guy in his 50s
uh kind of tall thin guy good looking
cool haircut
he looks like he should be in like
skinny puppy or knit
it's got a a woman and a daughter
daughter's cute she's kind of like uh
kind of reminds me of like um kind of
like a young natalie portman a little
bit didn't she
yeah she's kind of coughed out and uh
in the movie her mom is a fortune teller
who uh you know
it come turns out i'm watching this [ __ ]
and the story is really good uh
it's about this guy who moves into a
house he's fixing it up
and he's out drinking that night and
he's
driving back home and he accidentally
runs over the neighbor's kid the little
goth girl she's out there sledding at
night for some insane reason
because she's a weirdo yeah i'm not
gonna [ __ ] spoil everything about the
movie because it's
you know you can see it on shutter for
free it's it's good it's a good movie
and it turns out he he kills her and
the mom kind of goes on a goes on an
investigation to try to figure out
how she died and then it becomes kind of
like a paranormal
[ __ ] like a weird vision question
yeah paranormal quest for vengeance
against this
kind of wrongful death and uh it's pr
it's pretty neat and i'm watching the
movie and we wait till the very end of
it
and the credits start rolling and like
five people worked on it
but all these three main leads they're
all they're all a real family in real
life
it's a it's a guy's wife and their
daughter that's what it's like this is
super cool
like so yeah i looked this up about the
movie is called the deeper you dig
this actually it's weird because we saw
the trailer for this
months ago like because i think we were
going to rent it on xbox it was one of
the ones that we had that we're like oh
that one you know so we watched the
trailer and i'm like
that looks weird and i'm into it so but
we never got around to watching it so
then like about a week ago
shutter added it and i was like oh cool
like maybe we can do it uh on there now
when i went and looked it up because
like i said the trailer looked like
bizarro and i was just kind of like i'm
intrigued so
um so i was like really interested in
watching it and then
it turns out that i guess when this came
out like i guess it premiered
at maybe like fantasia or fantastic fest
or whatever the hell that thing is
back in 2019 and apparently it went like
around to a whole bunch of different um
festivals and it got like a really lot
of buzz about it which is probably why
like shutter picked it up and the cool
thing about this
is that this is the one of like
the most indie of indie movies this is a
family
um the guy's name is john adams his
wife's name is
uh toby poser and their daughter's name
is zelda
yeah and all three of them are in this
they are not only in it they also
directed it
uh the guy did the score it's like they
did
pretty much everything like you said
they also have and i found this out
later but they also have another
daughter named lulu
and she usually works on their movies
because this isn't the first
movie they've made this is the first
horror movie they've made i think they
did a crime drama and like some other
kind before
um but so so this
fam little family yeah makes these
movies they made it in upstate new york
like around where they lived and it was
just like this really snowy
kind of like [ __ ] yeah setting was spot
on i liked the tone of the setting the
little town the snow and everything the
houses that was
correct thing to do is to set it where
you could
yeah that [ __ ] had a high impact i
liked how the movie looked how it felt
i felt like i was there that was that
was a good way of doing it yeah because
it was just like this really creepy like
isolating
like like i said you know we compare a
lot of things to the shining but it was
the same kind of thing where it just
looked like these big
like snowy skies a little bit around
because you know
it shows the downtown area yeah that's a
small small rural town
so you know where you are and but
driving around it kind of brought me
back to
winters in boston you know what i mean
if you were outside the city
yeah you know what i mean that's kind of
how it looked it kind of took me back to
that i
kind of felt how that i kind of felt
like i was there
it was a good movie it was yeah and it's
like now i'm not going to say like
um it's not it's like a
i will say it's kind of like it has a
straightforward story like you said
because it's kind of like the little
girl gets you know run over
well she's not little she's supposed to
be 14. she's supposed to be 14. she's
probably more like 18 and she's 70. i'm
not sure how old she is because like i
said
their other daughter lulu that also
works on their movies
um she normally works on it but she
didn't work on this one because she was
off at college
so i'm assuming she's like the older one
and i think zelda is the younger one
and i think zelda however old she is
she's a teenager i guess
and they gave her like a directing
credit on this as well so i thought that
was really cool so this is like one
little family
and they're just they do everything and
they're making movies and it doesn't
look like
this is not like ouija shark it's not
like anything like that this is a real
yeah like really nice looking movie yeah
it just goes to show you what kind of
technology
and talent is out there outside of the
hollywood scene
kind of you know this movie
this movie is kind of in the spirit of a
lot of [ __ ] really good
classic horror movies you know this is
how night of living dead was made in a
way
kind of to me it kind of felt like hills
have eyes in a certain way there are a
lot of homages
or influence like there was some roman
polanski
themes in it like you know the tenet it
kind of had a theme
little small influences from that i
could feel some influences of [ __ ]
um uh carpenter
and some influences of uh um
there's a guy that did the brood and
david carter yeah you know
i got a little bit of a cronenberg i got
a little bit of a lynchy environment
because this does have like nation
scenes some surreal like really
surreal like imagery in it yeah because
like i said it's mostly like
and i saw like one reviewer that
compared it to like a pretty recent
movie called a dark song
so which was an excellent excellent film
which was just like two people in a
house and it was like really creepy
so if you liked that movie you'll
probably like this one but this one
has is there's just something like
really really cool about it there's just
something like the tone of it is just
like really cool it's just like this
bleak
cold and it's just like and it's and
it's kind of slow-moving and kind of
ponderous like there's some scenes of
you know people just like kind of
walking through the woods and it's like
all quiet and everything
but it's like but then it's kind of
punctuated with these bizarro like after
the daughter gets killed
and like i said she's a psychic but i
guess at the beginning they kind of
imply that maybe she's like a fake she's
more of a tarot reader type of thing she
does like tarot cards she's a psychic
and reads tarot cards and then yeah
she's hooked in with a spiritual
underground of [ __ ]
mystics and uh one of them was kind of
like
reminding me a little bit of a kind of a
sinister version of [ __ ] halloran
from
from
the shredding shiny that dude was
wrapped it's cool yeah yeah he looked
great he looked great on [ __ ] camera
he really did yeah he was like kind of
really dark skinned and blonde and
[ __ ] he gave a really creepy perform
not blonde but bald and real
dark-skinned black guy and he just
the performance he gave was [ __ ]
creepy especially he got weirder as it
was
yeah as that scene went on yeah did he
um
nah [ __ ] i had no idea this was a
homemade movie just goes to show you
what's possible if you have talent you
care about your craft and another thing
is as the movies
unfolding i didn't realize all these
people were related
yeah we didn't know that there was a
fiddler but i knew i could
i could sense that they were all from
[ __ ] like a gothic industrial [ __ ]
culture
their background i could tell that they
were gods
well yeah because i mean the little girl
like zelda is the real name she plays
the
the character she plays is named echo
yeah and uh the mom's name is ivy
but it's um yeah she like looked like a
real little goth girl and you could tell
that like
i could tell that the dad was you know
what i mean they were all kind of into
the industrial scene and [ __ ]
and yeah it's just it and the mom was
cool too
what's funny is like they got her
dressed up in winter clothes and she
they got her in mom
mode so she kind of looks unmade up and
frumpy but when she was fighting you
could tell she was rocking quite a
figure man
yeah i was like okay
[Laughter]
yeah she looked good but yeah that was
just so i i just really really liked
there was just something very
unusual about the tone of this it was
just kind of like because we see a lot
of horror movies and a lot of them are
like
fine and um you know they're but they're
like nothing special
but this one like really stood out i
guess because it was like a really
even though like i said it's a sort of a
straightforward story but it had like
all this kind of creative [ __ ]
about the mom and like her getting her
psychic powers back and trying to find
out what happened to her daughter
and going on a sort of like i said
almost like a sort of vision quest or
like down through the
through hell or something like that but
like going internal
and like all the really weird like
surreal imagery that that entailed like
when she goes through all these steps
where she's trying to figure out like
what happened to her yeah that did feel
kind of lynchian didn't it the way all
this yeah
well particularly one scene i was just
kind of like oh inland empire somebody
saw it
yeah but you know i can't say that i i
could really sense the influences but
this was an
this was a very unique movie it really
was like the whole
vibe of it was like really really cool
very creative this is a talented
bunch and they thought about what they
were doing so this
is well thought out little movie it was
craft built
oh definitely not not homemade it's
homemade
didn't feel like it no very craft built
there's only one
scene that i didn't feel the audio was
quite up to par
and that was the one scene where the
mom's doing the
tarot card reading for the older lady oh
yeah yeah
the the audio quality through our sound
system has sounded a little bit low
quality
and the acting was a little bit wooden
for that little scene but it didn't
spoil the movie
yeah you know i think i think maybe a
couple other
i think maybe i would have used another
take or kept shooting it until the tank
to the till to the scene was kind of
fluid it felt a little wooden
but that's that's my only criticism yeah
and i didn't
honestly i didn't notice that at all it
was minor because yeah i was looking for
problems yeah this i mean this is a very
small cast but
the fact that this is just like
essentially one family and they
do everything they do the scores they do
the cinematography they do the camera
they do
every single thing and the fact that
they could put something together like
this that looked like that i would never
have
thought because like i said when you say
homemade movie i think yeah
i think of like widget shark yeah or
something like that we're just like you
know i just made it with it and it looks
like kind of
like you just made it with your friends
this is like a good art film this looks
like a real
movie and it's like the special effect
there were some pretty gruesome
effects in there dead dead animal parts
looks like a road kill i don't know if
it was real or not it looked real
i would imagine it probably is maybe
that's why they probably just went and
said hey maybe we just remembered rotten
bodies
yeah it looked good looked real good
that's what i'm saying there's
like some really good effects in this
and like i said the surreal imagery was
like
really really cool like i was into that
the soundtrack or soundscape i put it on
par with
like um hills have eyes which in a way
that that hills have eyes soundtrack was
like
the world's first industrial album it
was [ __ ] ahead of its time when you
heard it you know it wasn't quite
music but it was yeah because they
weren't really kind of like something
off a skinny puppy album you know
or like einstein
[Music]
yeah and it really really suited the
mood yeah suited the mood of the movie
so
well thought out i mean every little
element they're they're thinking about
what the budget that they have and the
abilities that they have how are they
going to get this thing to come across
as as high quality you know what i mean
yeah you can't get an orchestra
and if you use the [ __ ] you know
synthesizers it's not going to sound
like an orchestra so how
what kind of sounds track are you gonna
use well they kind of went with the
proto-industrial kind of
yeah so it's just mostly like sound
effects sound effects and it's kind of
like
intercut with like really old they use
like a lot of old like vaudevillian type
of tunes like through like a crackly
radiation yeah the radio effects [ __ ]
came out really good
yeah i liked how that came out
especially in the car shots it sounded
creepy and distant
voices i know what that's like when
you're driving through this [ __ ] snow
and back in the old days we had the
radio on it kind of had a weird
alienating quality to it yeah and then
at the end
it it goes into the [ __ ] credits and
there was actually a cool song on the
end of it
yeah it really i really liked the song
at the end i can't remember who it was
by it i had to go back and look at it
but yeah it's like that it was just so
cool and it's like even
when we were watching it like some of
the shots like the one shot of her like
in the orange
like hunting jacket like just walking
through this forest that was just like
all white
and it was just like a really really
nicely framed kind of shot every time so
this is like a really good looking movie
and like i said the whole
you know the fact that they i'm assuming
that that's where they live these like
up in the catskills or it's like up in
upstate new york somewhere i can't
remember the name of the um town where
they shot it
because i did i did see it on imdb but i
can't remember it was like it's not even
a town it's like a hamlet
like they would call it so but they shot
it there so i don't know if that's where
they live
so i'm definitely going to be checking
out some of their other uh
movies because apparently i didn't know
that but you know they had made a couple
other movies before this but this is
their first horror movie and this is
kind of
um the one that's gotten them the most
uh attention
and like i said this only cost eleven
thousand dollars this cost eleven
thousand dollars
this is done by a hollywood studio it
would have been millions
millions it had been about three million
yeah and i've seen three million dollar
movies that were not
nearly as good as this one just goes to
show you what
efficiency can do for a movie
interesting too because it seems like on
rotten tomatoes i think it had what like
97
or something that was i think that was
that was the critic score the audience
score was like in the 70s or 80s yeah um
because i can see if you're not like
into like arty movies you may not know
or like
or like slow movies you'll be like what
the [ __ ] is this weird-ass [ __ ] but it's
like
i mean i knew it was going to be weird
from the trailer like you can tell that
it's a kind of a weird movie from the
trailer because there's like some really
kind of bizarre imagery
um so i was kind of like all right i'm
down it's not really a slow movie though
it it's taking its time yeah because of
the kind of movie that it is but the
edit is paced
well because it because it kind of
pulled me into it early on
yeah so i'm letting it take its time
which surprised me because i didn't know
if you because i'm i'm
i was watching the beginning and i dug
it but i was like i don't know if tom's
gonna like yeah i'm real sensitive to
[ __ ] up ed right
[Laughter]
and i'm real sensitive to [ __ ] bad
bad characterizations and bad
storytelling
i was pulled into the movie so i mean i
really really liked the acting in this
too because
i think the cool thing about it is that
even though you don't
you don't know a great deal about these
characters backstories
you know what i mean they don't like go
into a lot of [ __ ] about you know what
happened in their past or anything
they're just kind of
there they are and but you still got and
i guess
you know who they were though yeah you
knew who they were and i guess that was
kind of like a testament to their acting
and the fact that they were all a family
which like i said i didn't know when we
first watched it
yeah so you really got a sense of these
kind of like lived-in
characters yeah you know what i mean
rather than just
you know there's no like exposition
about you know where they came from or
what happened in the past or what you
know where
where ekko's dad is where like where did
that guy come from where did he move
from there's nothing like that because
it's not necessary that's the strength
of this
that's the strength of the movie though
i cannot stand
dialogue heavy movies i'm not here to be
explained to i want you to show me i
don't want you to tell me
so the movie is not dialogue heavy it
just has just what it needs
and it doesn't yes it's very economical
right
in that way right so now the script and
you know the script and the direction
that's that's it that's you got it just
right with that yeah i'm like i'm super
like
jacked for what these people because
yeah like i said they made some movies
before but this is the first one that's
kind of gotten them like a wide kind of
thing and yeah
you know we saw we saw the trailer a
while back which you can
see that looks good yeah and then so
it because it made such a splash at like
a lot of the um
festivals last year shutter eventually
picked it up so
shutter just added it a while back so we
got to see it
it made a splash you know because
the holistic all of it together has good
quality you know i mean it's a good
quality movie but really i think what
does it is it's
efficient no-nonsense storytelling
that's really
what did it yeah because when you start
[ __ ] up your storytelling
and the edit people fall out of the
movie
yeah yeah like i said it didn't need a
an over
thing of characterization it didn't need
all of that you got the story you got
what was going on
um and then it was just kind of like
went off in this bizarre direction and
you just kind of like let it take
and it does they did kind of the right
thing the way they ended it it ended
with kind of like action horror scenes
which
which kind of brought it to a climax i
agreed with ending it the way that they
did
um it then there's a twist at the end of
it too which is kind of weird but you
just got to see the movie
yeah it's like it's not i i guess it
wasn't so much a twist because they did
set it up they set it up you know it was
common
yeah yeah i mean i wasn't sure exactly
confirmed
yeah i wasn't sure exactly what like
what form
the end was going to take yeah but like
from some of the stuff she said like
earlier on
i was just kind of like oh they're
setting up but i didn't know like
exactly how it was going to like play
out you know what i mean
that little that ending the those final
few seconds which confirmed what you
thought was going on really did go
the movie could have been watched either
with or without that i think that was
actually opposite
uh uh optional yeah they included that
ending
yeah you probably could have ended it
right when the [ __ ] thing
i can't spoil it yeah you could have
lost i know what i mean you could have
locked that off
like those last couple seconds yeah you
could have locked the last few seconds
off and
it still would have been good yeah it
still had been worked because then it
would have been in your mind well what
did that actually happen
yeah so i think an alternative it works
either way it works either way an
alternate edit would also work
it was good though yeah i enjoyed it
all right you uh are you done yeah let's
see if everybody's well yeah because a
couple people came in and they just
snuck in late and i was like now i feel
really
bad cause it's like no i feel really bad
cause we're like done talking about the
baby
but man i gotta go i'm hungry man i
haven't like oh yeah there's stuff in
there
i got i haven't eaten since i got eight
o'clock this morning and now
now it's like 3 30 and i'm like really
really hungry all right i'll feed you
all right
shut it down all right so uh we'll be
back tomorrow for another live stream
probably tomorrow i will uh talk about
haunting a blind manor because i
watched uh one or two more episodes last
night and i will finish watching it
tomorrow
and uh or i'll finish watching it
tonight rather and tomorrow morning
and then i can review that for you guys
because i know some people have asked me
about doing that
and uh so stay tuned for that and like i
said if you have shutter check out the
deeper you dig it's really really cool
like i said if you like like surreal
like
already weird horror movies that was
made by like a cool little family
so uh all right we'll see you guys
tomorrow bye